on this wednesday night canada's
increasing interest rate the cost of
borrowing takes a hike again it's
stressful the impacts on mortgages and
small businesses the homicides of two
metis hunters they painted it up as if
he was a violent he was an alcoholic the
same old stereotypes the victim's family
fighting racism while fighting for
justice defending the donbass region i
stay here and i
fight for people's life the battle for
ukraine's industrial heartland
and do you find that mr depp the verdict
is in do you find that misheard at a
salacious celebrity court case has
proven all the elements of defamation
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
canada central bank announced another
oversized hike of its key interest rate
it's the third increase this year in an
attempt to curb soaring inflation rates
the bank of canada raised its rate by
half a percentage point to 1.5 percent
it's the first back to back half point
hike since scheduled rate announcements
began more than two decades ago today
the bank is signaling canadians should
be prepared for further benchmark boosts
these consecutive aggressive rate hikes
haven't been seen in more than a quarter
century and gaviola explains how this
impacts household budgets and businesses
in our top story tonight
it's stressful this mother of two runs
her photography studio from home taking
clients when her three-year-old is at
daycare and while her newborn naps
today's rate hike means her monthly
variable rate mortgage payments are
going up by more than a hundred dollars
after a similar increase in april as a
small business owner that can hurt if i
don't have a busy month on a 700
thousand dollar mortgage with a typical
five-year variable rate of 1.9 percent
amortized over 25 years monthly mortgage
payments would climb from just over 2
900 to more than 3 000. that's an extra
170 a month or more than 2 000 a year
rate hikes and the expectation of more
to come have already had a cooling
effect on the housing market but the
impact on small businesses has just
begun according to the canadian
federation of independent business two
out of three small businesses have taken
on debt during the pandemic averaging
160 thousand dollars in the past two
years you add to that the supply chain
issues you add to that the labor
shortages all of that is creating a lot
of financial pressure on small
businesses right now the cfib is calling
for more support for small businesses
still reeling from covid restrictions
that gave larger rivals an even bigger
financial edge the impact for us longer
term is it continues to put pressure on
proper margins
as well as with inflation this owner of
two small retail shops in windsor
ontario says his variable rate debt has
become more expensive as the cost of the
items he stocks climbs to we've seen
some products go up by two or three
hundred percent from last year in terms
of cost the central bank says it's
prepared to act more forcefully to tame
inflation which is soaring close to
seven percent well above the bank's two
percent target its next interest rate
decision is july 13th and with consumer
and business spending strong
unemployment at a record low another
outsized rate hike is expected ann
gaviola global news toronto
canada's privacy watchdogs say fast food
giant tim hortons violated the law and
misled customers by unnecessarily
collecting data from users of its mobile
app without their consent
tim's even though we did not use the
information for marketing purposes
uh was still collecting where people
where its users were every few minutes
every day that's that's a egregious form
of
surveillance
officials say the mobile ordering app
misled users to believe the geo-location
information it gathered would only be
accessed when the app was in use in
reality the company was tracking users
as long as their device was on and their
data was never used for the stated
purpose of advertising and promotions
tim hortons has agreed to delete users
data and establish a privacy management
program
the canadian government is again
concerned about china's aggression
toward canada sources tell global news
that chinese pilots are displaying
dangerous behavior toward canadian
military crews who are in the air and
they're not stopping despite warnings
from our federal government mercedes
stephenson explains
i can't get them off my tail
high speed high flying fighter jet dog
fights and narrowly buzzing control
towers it's the stuff of high adrenaline
action movies though for modern
militaries more like juvenile relics of
the past
but global news has learned that china
is putting royal canadian air force
crews in the danger zone with high risk
high aggression tactics in international
airspace
the chinese military is using what
sources called dangerous maneuvers to
intercept canadian intelligence aircraft
currently on a u.n mission to enforce
sanctions against north korea fast and
agile chinese fighter jets are buzzing
canada's slower aurora aircraft with
razor thin margins frequently zooming
past the planes a mere 20 to 100 feet
away
creating enough turbulence alone that
canadian planes could be thrown off
course or risk a mid-air collision it
would be terrifying for them to do any
kind of evasive maneuver because they
might
trick the chinese fighter pilot into
doing something even more irresponsible
and more dangerous so the best they can
do is fly along and hope that the
chinese fighter pilot doesn't make a
mistake the chinese pilots are so close
multiple sources told global news the
canadians can make eye contact with them
and see the chinese pilots flipping them
the middle finger senior military
officials are concerned it risks the
safety and even the lives of canadian
crews and this isn't a case of a single
pilot hot dogging sources say there have
been approximately 60 intercepts since
christmas and nearly half of those have
been dangerous the canadian government
has sent multiple official diplomatic
rebukes to china calling the maneuver
unsafe and unprofessional
all to no avail the fact that the
chinese government is not responding to
canadian concerns seeking to
rein this kind of
adventurism
in is also very concerning one source
told global news pilots and commanders
carefully assessed the risk before each
flight takes off but there is growing
concern that the new tactics signal a
new tone from china nithu
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes
prime minister justin trudeau says
ottawa won't pursue a national
decriminalization of certain drugs
without putting systems and supports in
place his comments come a day after
british columbia was granted a
three-year exemption from federal drug
laws the province will decriminalize
simple possession of some illicit drugs
starting next year to deal with the
opioid crisis
working with the jurisdiction that
wanted to do it was priority for us and
of course we've already heard cities
like toronto and edmonton interested in
taking this on as well we're going to
work with them and try to make sure
every step of the way that as and if we
move forward
it is not just a single solution that it
is a a full wrap around approach like
we're trying to create in bc
this afternoon an ndp bill to expand
decriminalization across the country was
voted down in the house of commons
an alberta father and son have been
found guilty in connection to the deaths
of two metis hunters maurice cardinal
and his nephew jacob sansom were shot
and killed more than two years ago while
hunting northeast of edmonton tonight
their family is speaking with brianna
carsten smith about the racism they
experienced while seeking justice for
their loved ones
hours after guilty verdicts in the
deaths of their loved ones sarah and
gina sansom are still reeling after two
weeks of testimony morris and jake were
on trial
not anthony and roger jacob santam and
his uncle maurice cardinal were shot and
killed in march 2020. tuesday anthony
bilido and his father roger were found
guilty but the sansoms say the justice
is tainted because throughout the trial
defense lawyers tried to prove the metis
men had been drunk and aggressive they
painted it up as if he was a violent
he was an alcoholic
the same old stereotypes they paint
indigenous peoples as if his name his
family who he was as a person does not
exist how are they talking about jake
and morris like it doesn't seem
like they're talking about them because
that's not who they were the billados
spotted a vehicle they didn't recognize
near their property chasing it down a
rural road believing the strangers were
thieves no evidence of theft was ever
found when the vehicles stopped a fight
started anthony testified he shot the
victims in self-defense the younger
billado was found guilty of the
second-degree murder of cardinal but the
lesser charge of manslaughter in the
death of sansom barish was able to
convince
a jury that my brother was a violent
drunk
a violent drunk
even though my brother was none of those
things every day in our courtrooms i ask
witnesses regardless of their background
about alcohol because we know alcohol
affects a whole bunch of
issues that are important in a trial
like perception judgment response we
asked all witnesses that still the
family believes changes are necessary
right across canada so indigenous
criminal cases are treated differently
that's a cultural safe space practice is
educating lawyers educating the air cnp
educating the crown educating even our
judges to look for these things and the
jury will need to be instructed in these
things a legacy these women will work
towards now that there's been a guilty
verdict
brianna karsten smith global news
edmonton
a group of indigenous leaders met with
roman catholic bishops in winnipeg today
to discuss reconciliation and their
expectations of pope francis's visit to
canada next month
three locations were picked
the survivors had no say in that
the pontiff has scheduled stops in
edmonton quebec city and ecallute but
worries are growing that survivors won't
be able to travel to those three cities
during the pope's visit at the end of
july the group asked the bishops if the
papal visit could be expanded to more
locations but say so far the answer has
been no however they are hopeful that
the pontiff will say the right thing
when he comes
he has to
say
i am sorry
for what happened
to your
people on your children
on behalf of the catholic church
he says he believes the catholic church
will stand in support of survivors in
creating agreements on issues such as
treaty implementation and the calls to
action in the truth and reconciliation
commission report
a jury in virginia has sided with
pirates of the caribbean star johnny
depp in his defamation trial against
ex-wife amber hurd but both hollywood
actors have been found guilty of
defamation over claims of abuse before
and during their brief marriage
as against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars
as against amber heard
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of five million dollars
the jury found her defame dep in a 2018
washington post op-ed in which she
referred to herself as a public figure
representing domestic abuse depp was not
named in the article but claimed it
destroyed his reputation however jurors
also found depp defamed heard through
his attorney and awarded her two million
dollars
the weapons on keeve's wish list coming
up what the west is sending to help
ukraine fight russia
western allies pledged to deliver more
weapons to ukraine today including the
long-range artillery that keeve has been
asking for
we are mindful of the escalation risk
and everything we're doing associated
with this but at the same time russia
doesn't get a veto
over what we sent to the ukrainians the
ukrainians didn't start this war the
russians did
the u.s says a new 700 million dollar
support package will include training
for ukrainians on its advanced rocket
systems something that hasn't been done
out of fears they would be used to fire
into russian territory the pentagon says
it has received assurances from ukraine
that won't happen germany says it's also
sending more weapons including
anti-aircraft missiles and radar systems
the kremlin has called the west's latest
pledge a move to directly and
intentionally add fuel to the fire in
ukraine but it comes as russian forces
continue to gain ground in eastern
donbass and inch closer to capturing
another key city jeff semple is in the
region for us tonight
this is the next stop on russia's war
path
a rocket slammed into this residential
street in the east ukrainian city of
slovense
at least three people were killed
especially
it shattered our windows and shook the
building she says i'm planning to leave
to keeve russia is closing in on this
city just 12 kilometers from the front
line russian forces now on the cusp of
capturing luhansk and surrounding
ukrainian-held territory in donetsk the
two provinces make up the dawn bass
ukraine's industrial heartland and
russia's stated target if russian forces
do come to slaviansk these trenches will
be the last line of defense vladimir
putin has said since the beginning that
he's coming to liberate russian-speaking
communities in the donbass from what he
calls a ukrainian genocide but what we
have found talking to people here is
just the opposite ordinary civilians who
are digging trenches taking up arms and
preparing to fight
this gym teacher is now an officer in
the civil defense battalion
we hope our western partners will send
weapons to help us he says but even if
they don't we will do everything we can
to protect our home
air raid sirens now blare almost
non-stop in the neighboring city of
kramatorsk three-quarters of its two
hundred thousand residents have fled but
some can't albino vona morova lives
alone in this mostly abandoned blown out
apartment building
i can't move i have no money she says i
grew up in russia there are brothers why
would they do this for those left behind
volunteers are providing food
before the war katarina onoshenka was a
lawyer i'm a fighter
so
i stay here and i fight for people's
life a couple of months ago she was
handing out food at this local train
station ten minutes after she left an
explosion it's terrible sound she
returned to find this a russian cluster
bomb hit the crowded station 59 people
were killed onoshenko took this photo of
the russian rocket bearing the words for
the children i don't know why
what children they mean
what about
i don't know
for my children no i don't know the
mayor says many here used to be
pro-russian not anymore now it's not not
thinkable he told global news the war is
at a critical crossroads the next two
weeks are very important for ukraine it
will depend for us first of all how long
can we hold
this line the answer could determine the
fate of the donbass and perhaps even the
war
jeff temple global news sloviensk
[Music]
the wrath of agatha ahead the deadly
hurricane wreaking havoc on southern
mexico
[Music]
in southern mexico 11 people are dead
and dozens are missing in the wake of
hurricane agatha
the storm triggered flooding and
landslides across the state of oaxaca
most of the victims were swept away by
rivers or buried in mudslides agatha
made landfall monday as a category two
hurricane one of the strongest may
storms ever to hit mexico's pacific
coast the atlantic hurricane season
begins today forecasters are predicting
above normal activity with as many as 21
named storms
scientists believe they found the
biggest plant in the world but it's
probably not what you're picturing
researchers discovered this underwater
meadow of sea grass called poseidon's
ribbon weed they found it in shark bay a
world heritage site in western australia
initially the meadow was thought to be a
cluster of thousands of individual
species but scientists now think it's
all just one genetically identical plant
that's at least 4 500 years old the
grass covers more than 180 square
kilometers
next britain on the eve of celebration
for the monarch's historic milestone
royal fans are converging on london
where final preparations are underway
for the four-day celebration of queen
elizabeth ii platinum jubilee tonight
the royal family has unveiled a new
portrait to mark her 70 years on the
throne
given the queen's age and her condition
lately one of the big questions is how
much the monarch will be seen during
these events our donna friesen is in
london on the eve of the jubilee donna
nathu it's probably safe to say no 96
year old has ever had a birthday
celebration like this queen elizabeth
has ruled longer than any british
monarch and plans are in place to
celebrate her 70-year reign in style
over an extended holiday weekend here
from tourist hot spots to buckingham
palace the stage is set to celebrate a
royal milestone and the queen's super
fans are prepared to camp out all night
to get a front row seat she deserves
this she deserves us to celebrate what a
wonderful 70 years she's given to us
this celebration is our thank you to her
it was 70 years ago that queen elizabeth
ascended to the throne after her father
died
now the final rehearsals are over led by
her grandson prince william to mark a
lifetime of service they didn't used to
have platinum jubilees quite simply
because monarchs didn't live this long
katie nichol is a journalist and author
of the new royals and i think what we've
seen during the queen's reign is that
unstinting devotion to duty mobility
issues according to the palace means
she's cut back on public events but this
is a job for life we are expecting to
see the queen on the balcony with some
members of her family do you think we'll
see much more of her i'm told by
buckingham palace that it really is
going to be a case of decisions being
made on the day what's certain is there
will be no repeat of this
only working royals will appear on the
balcony of buckingham palace not prince
andrew and not harry and megan though
they are here for the weekend do you
think there will be family drama with
their visit well i can tell you that the
instruction from the very top and that
is hmq is that no family dramas or
tensions are to overshadow any part of
this jubilee she has devoted supporters
who love her and who know this moment
is likely not going to be repeated look
there's no doubt that
a monarch that reigns
that long
pretty successfully
and has that much affection you know a
bond with her subjects here and around
the world is it is an almost impossible
act to follow
but i think this is a moment for people
to take stock of what she's achieved and
say thank you
not everyone of course will be
celebrating there are critics who say
this is just a display of colonial
nostalgia
yet there are people who can separate
their fondness and affection for the
queen from their feelings about the
institution of the monarchy itself and
tens of thousands of people are expected
to line the route for her birthday
parade tomorrow
nifu
thanks donna and you can join donna
tomorrow when she'll bring you global
national from london
but that's global national for this
wednesday night i'm nitu garcia
tonight's your canada is the springtime
shot of the downtown edmonton skyline
and the walter dale bridge thanks for
watching and have a great night
[Music]
you